buenos días
la movilidad eléctrica el coche
eléctrico mejora la calidad del aire de
las ciudades
hoy como cada día van a morir en españa'
65 personas según la agencia europea del
medio ambiente por respirar una mala
calidad del aire
[Música]
en la foto vemos la ciudad de madrid
madrid es un ejemplo muy significativo
porque alrededor de madrid en la
cercanía de madrid no hay industria con
lo cual la contaminación que vemos
proviene en gran parte del tráfico
este es además un problema que tiende a
crecer los europeos
vivimos en su mayoría en ciudades en el
entorno urbano con lo cual estamos ante
un problema muy grave de salud pública
el coche eléctrico es parte de la
solución es un coche que no tiene tubo
de escape no tiene emisiones
hoy en día nos llama la atención cómo
era posible no hace muchos años se podía
fumar en bares en el autobús en el avión
hoy nos parece impensable bueno yo creo
que la buena noticia es que estamos
ahora mismo en el camino para que dentro
de no muchos años nos llame igualmente
la atención cómo era posible que
podíamos pasear por nuestras ciudades
con coches muy cerca de nosotros
emitiendo gases muy perjudiciales para
la salud muy cerca
hay un conjunto de partículas que está
europa en lo que llamamos el pm 25 qué
significa esto pm hace referencia a las
iniciales en inglés de material
particulado y 2.5 hace referencia al
tamaño de las partículas dos con cinco
son micras es decir son partículas de un
tamaño menor en igual o inferior a 2.5
micras son partículas tan pequeñas tan
pequeñas que si las inhalamos si entran
dentro de nuestro cuerpo pueden acabar
en cualquier órgano
bueno pues es un hecho científicamente
demostrado y yo tuve la oportunidad de
estudiarlo en gijón que más del 35% de
las partículas pm2 5 que respiramos
viene del tráfico
para hacer este estudio lo que se hace
es una muestra una muestra
diariamente durante un año entero
de partículas pm2 5 hacer un análisis de
qué elementos químicos quedan contenidos
en esa muestra y mediante técnicas de
análisis estadístico y matemático
determinar las fuentes de emisión de
esas partículas insisto en que el
resultado es demoledor más del 35 por
ciento de lo que respiramos proviene del
tráfico
bueno como nos metimos los humanos en
este lío porque el coche para moverse
necesita energía
no solo el coche de cualquier actividad
humana pensamos por ejemplo la
agricultura necesita energía empezamos
utilizando la energía de los animales y
a medida que fuimos avanzando las
civilizaciones utilizábamos máquinas
cada vez más cantidad de energía la
industria pasa lo mismo cualquier
sociedad industrializada requiere de
grandes cantidades de energía pensemos
en los servicios un restaurante un hotel
también requiere energía en nuestras
casas también necesitamos energía para
tener un frigorífico una lavadora para
generar calor
el calor es una forma de energía es
decir que la energía está presente en
toda actividad humana es más el consumo
energético es un indicador del grado de
desarrollo de las sociedades
la energía forma parte de la propia vida
y nosotros dentro de nuestro organismo
estamos continuamente con procesos que
consumen también energía tiene también
ese toque digamos místico
quizá espiritual de dónde viene la
energía no cuál es el origen de energía
que eso probablemente depara a otra tras
otra charla
bueno curiosamente el coche empezó
siendo eléctrico allá por 1900 poco
empezó a ver coches eléctricos sin
embargo de repente todo cambió y sobre
todo a partir de la primera y segunda
guerra mundial se empezó a apostar por
el petróleo como fuente de energía
primaria principal de hecho el petróleo
sigue siendo la principal fuente de
energía que consumimos los humanos esto
desarrolló muchísimo el motor de
combustión interna y los coches tal como
los conocemos hasta ahora
tiene sentido si pensamos que es una
manera fácil de almacenar energía es
tener un depósito de combustible y una
manera fácil de mover la energía a un
sitio para otro es mover ese depósito de
combustible
sin embargo en los últimos años se
vuelve a hablar del coche eléctrico
y yo creo que hay tres factores por los
cuales se vuelve a hablar del coche
eléctrico el primero de ellos lo más
importante es la mayor conciencia
ambiental es decir nos preocupamos ahora
mismo que vimos antes que la población
está aumentando pues que haya un mundo
sostenible es decir que nos preocupa y
al calentamiento global nos preocupan
las emisiones y esa preocupación está
llegando un sector que curiosamente yo
creo que ha estado un poco dormido en
cuanto ponerse las pilas a buscar
energías alternativas que es el sector
del transporte
ese sería el primer factor el segundo
factor yo creo que es la aparición de la
batería de ión-litio y todos tenemos una
aunque la hemos apagado pero todos
tenemos ahora mismo una batería de
ión-litio en nuestros en nuestros
bolsillos
la batería del coche es exactamente
igual que la del móvil solo que es más
grande en todo el suelo del coche al
final es batería para tener una
autonomía pues que nos permita movernos
tiene una bondad respecto a baterías
anteriores que es que permite muchísimos
ciclos de carga y descarga y perdió
aquel efecto memoria por cual nos
recomendaban agotar la batería antes de
volver a cargarla no entonces es una
revolución importante y el tercer y
último factor la verdad que es
importante recordar la tecnología y la
digitalización vuelve a estar de moda lo
que estos dos grandes genios de la
humanidad que tenemos en la en la foto
discutieron hace más de cien años que es
si el mundo eléctrico iba a ser dominado
por la corriente continua la corriente
alterna bueno pues gracias a la
tecnología el paso de una a otra ahora
mismo es muy fácil y porque vuelva con
estar de moda porque la batería almacena
corriente continua y la energía que
llega a nuestras casas llega en forma de
corriente alterna entonces es necesario
en este mundo pasar de una forma de
energía a otra
la corriente continua es aquella que no
cambia la polaridad en el tiempo
pensemos una pila o en una batería
edison pensaba que se iban poner en esta
forma de energía eléctrica no que la
corriente continua iba a mandar por
contra tesla y otros también valoraban
la energía alterna como la energía
eléctrica del futuro la energía alterna
es aquella que cambio de polaridad en el
tiempo que tiene esa forma de onda
senoidal 250 veces que tenemos en europa
y que permite que se pueda transportar
la energía a través de redes de
transporte y distribución minimizando
mucho las pérdidas
insisto en que esta guerra de las
corrientes vuelve a estar de rabiosa
actualidad actualidad por eso a los que
nos gusta mucho el coche eléctrico y
todo este mundo nos gusta mucho un grupo
que se llama cdc que seguro que conocéis
porque a cdc son las iniciales de
corriente alterna corriente continua
bueno ya somos ya conocemos bastante en
torno al coche eléctrico con esta charla
que estamos compartiendo pero queremos
llegar a ser llegáis a conocer mucho más
para ser gerais necesitamos fijar dos
conceptos más el primer concepto es el
tema de las unidades y de una división
que nos va a solucionar muchísimos
problemas y va a dar respuesta a
muchísimas preguntas que nos hacen
nuestros cuñados en las comidas
familiares y demás no es cuánto tarda en
cargarse un coche eléctrico bueno pues
para ello hay que tener claro que la
energía se mide en kilovatios hora
kilovatios hora todo seguido nada de
kilovatios partido por hora cada vez que
alguien escribe kilovatios partido por
hora muere un gatito con lo cual
queremos como los gatitos no kilovatio
sobre todo seguido y no son kilómetros
horas son kilovatios obra todos seguidos
y no son tampoco kilovatios eso es una
deformación que tenemos muchos
electricistas que vivimos en este
mundillo
esta batería almacena 33 kilovatios está
mal dicho son kilovatios ahora vale la
batería almacena energía de dicho
batería y energía riman
y son en kilovatios hora lo que se mide
en kilovatios es la potencia
entonces disponemos cargadores de
diferentes potencias cargadores lentos y
cargadores rápidos entonces la magia de
estos tanques y / energía entre potencia
tengo el tiempo yo puedo dar respuesta a
cualquiera que me pregunté cuánto tiempo
tarda en cargar un coche eléctrico
ejemplo tenemos un coche eléctrico de 33
kilovatios horas
ahora mismo hay coches con baterías de
33 de 45 de 60 incluso de 90 y todo esto
va creciendo en un cargador doméstico de
3.6 kilovatios cuánto tiempo tardará
bueno pues vivimos 33 entre 36 sale
aproximadamente en 9 horas
la gente va a decir juego pues nueve
horas cargando el coche la verdad que
vaya pero cuánto tiempo está el
coche parado en casa en el trabajo
muchísimo tiempo
entonces en nueve horas tenemos tiempo
de sobra para cargar la batería de más
en unas condiciones muy buenas que van a
preservar la vida de la batería mucho
más porque él si le meto mucha potencia
me estoy cargando un poquito la vida de
la batería vale
el segundo concepto que tenemos que
manejar es un teorema que me inventé yo
que es el teorema de la niña bonita que
es saber más o menos cuánto consume un
coche eléctrico de los más vendidos los
coches más caros consume un poquito más
los más grandes pero anda en torno a los
15 kilovatios ahora a las 100 entonces
esto ya nos permite manejar conceptos
como llegáis a tal manera que la batería
de 33 kilovatios ahora con este consumo
de 15 kilovatios ahora a los 100
kilómetros nos da una autonomía de 200
kilómetros lo veis así de fácil
vale sabiendo eso ya los ha visto
[Música]
muy bien vamos a profundizar un poco más
sin embargo pese a estas ventajas de que
el coche eléctrico mejora la calidad de
la idea las ciudades no tiene tubo
escape no hay emisiones
hay gente que se enfada al oír hablar
del coche eléctrico curiosamente se
muestra bastante enfadado pero sin
embargo también mucha gente somos muy
felices hablando del coche eléctrico y
creemos que puede ser una solución muy
buena para toda la sociedad
los enfadados los enfadados a veces nos
muestran argumentos como diciendo sí sí
pero de dónde viene la energía eléctrica
con la que funciona el coche vienen
centrales que contaminan y centrales
además que están contribuyendo al
calentamiento global bueno pues hay que
decirles que
ahora mismo el mix energético en españa
por ejemplo el año pasado fue de cerca
del 38 por ciento fue de origen
renovable y yo conlleva a que utilizando
coches eléctricos considerando la
energía en el origen baja en un 65% las
emisiones de co2 que sabéis que es el
gas principal que ocasiona el
calentamiento global
otro argumento que utilizan los
enfadados es que el coche eléctrico no
es eficiente bueno pues a los que dicen
que el coche eléctrico no es eficiente
hay que decirles que es tres veces más
eficiente convertir energía eléctrica en
energía en movimiento respecto a
convertir energía en a solo gasolina a
energía en movimiento vale
y el otro argumento que se utiliza
normalmente también es que el coche
eléctrico es muy caro
aquí los enfados tiene un poquito de
razón sin embargo si echamos las cuentas
completas y vemos lo que cuesta la
electricidad respecto al gas solo la
gasolina y el menor mantenimiento que
tiene los coches eléctricos se consiguen
ahorros cuatro veces uno respecto a otro
es decir que hay que echar los números
completos el coche eléctrico es muy
sencillo tiene muchísimas menos piezas
vale no tiene circuitos auxiliares no
tienes que llevarlo tanta revisión no
lleva aceite etcétera etcétera y además
hay otra buena noticia ahora mismo las
marcas ya están obligadas por la
legislación europea a cumplir con una
cuota de emisiones de co2 con lo cual va
a tener que poner muchos modelos
eléctricos en el mercado a partir de
este año 2020 en una senda además
creciente hasta 2025 de este modo
cuantos más coches eléctricos hay en el
mercado más opciones hay ya
probablemente empieza a haber una guerra
de precios también entre marcas que
favorecerá también a que el coche
eléctrico sea muchísimo más asequible
bueno estamos llegando y al final y os
pido la reflexión sobre utilizar la
energía de forma positiva yo creo que
está en nuestra mano cambiar el concepto
de transporte
cambiar esa concepción que tenemos del
transporte y utilizar la energía de
forma eficiente y la energía que mejor
nos convenga en cada momento para que
esto sea más sostenible permitirme hacer
un ejercicio muy muy sencillo para
simplemente ver que somos capaces además
nosotros de generar energía positiva es
un ejercicio que me inventé yo hace años
y es que cuando no tienes ganas de
reírte si te empiezas a reír sin ganas
te acabas viendo con ganas y algo así si
te acaba riendo
vamos a hacerlo todos juntos por favor a
la de tres vamos a empezar a reino sin
ganas y vamos a comprobar si realmente
nos acabamos riendo con ganas de estar
preparados
coges aire una dos y tres
[Risas]
i
veis que realmente realmente nos
acabamos riendo estamos generando
energía positiva y yo creo que merece la
pena hacer esta reflexión acordaros por
favor de que el coche eléctrico mejora
la calidad de la vida de las ciudades
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]